social media has become part of our
nature we post we share we like we
follow we unfollow we subscribe but how
is social media affecting us a small
study of twenty college students found a
correlation between students who
demonstrated higher levels of Facebook
addiction and activity in the amygdala
striatal system while they interacted
with Facebook signals this activation
was the same seen in those with
substance addiction in a 2016 UCLA study
teens were split into two groups one was
shown a photo with the high number of
likes and the other group was shown the
same photo but with fewer likes those
who viewed the photo with more likes
were more likely to like the photo
themselves than the group who saw the
photo it's fewer likes again it was the
same picture this experiment found
activity in multiple parts of the brain
when teens saw photos they took receive
a lot of likes in particular the study
found significant activity in part of
the brain's reward circuitry known as
the nucleus accumbens dopamine is
released in the brain after positive
social stimuli such as likes and
positive comments on social media that
photos she just posted she got a bunch
of likes releasing dopamine into her
brain and causing a feeling of
satisfaction
[Music]
psychologist BF Skinner found that mice
would respond to certain stimuli they
knew resulted in our award more often
when the reward came at variable times
this theory can also be applied to
social media and the times we check it
looking for a reward in terms of a like
comment or message we habitually check
our accounts but we are not always
rewarded maybe this photo didn't get the
amount of life's you wanted so you will
try again and again and again looking
for that reward but wait something else
have you ever felt your phone vibrate
what it really didn't according to
robert rosenberger of the Georgia
Institute of Technology we become so
connected to our phones that they've
sort of become part of our bodies
anytime something stimulates our
triggers sensation in an area where you
keep your phone you might believe it's
your phone this is called phantom
vibration syndrome
studies show that nearly 90% of people
report experiencing these phantom
vibrations
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]